I'm going to sit here.
Okay.
And I can pause as well?
Yes.
Yeah, I
have not done a tournament in a really long
time, and I wasn't sure exactly
how it was going to start, so I was
not the
most ready at the beginning
to do, I was not expecting
to bow in, so that is why I didn't
do that properly.
Um,
so
once we started, I'm definitely the most
familiar with the first few moves.
Um,
this
front, this first bit here,
the body, body, front kick, back
fist, body, front kick, back fist, body, back
fist, I always kind of say that
in my head, I don't do that for a lot of my poomsae's,
but for some reason, this one in
particular, I kind of have
those first, that kind of,
not even the first, like, aside from the
initial branch offs, but the
kind of that first forward bit, kind of the
moves kind of play in my head as I'm
doing them. Um,
which, I'm not quite sure,
that's actually part of the reason why I chose to do this one, just because
it has been a really long time since I've
competed, and the fact that I just remembered
some of it literally kind of in a rhythm in my head
was part of the reason why I chose to do that.
Um, I was trying
to make sure that my
strikes were at the right height, and that I was
kind of snapping a little bit, not
sure how well I did
that, but I was trying.
Um, that bit, this bit here,
um, I'm always trying,
I remember my instructor telling me a few years
ago, um, the footwork there is kind of
tricky, because I'm trying to
um, make sure that I'm pivot, I'm not
over-pivoting or doing, like, little baby steps,
kind of in
in the middle,
um, and just having it be
one solid motion with the feet to, into
the, um,
yeah, looking at it, I don't think
my hands were quite as straight as they could have
been, but
yeah.
Um, I think
at the end I am always kind of thinking
the moves in my head as I'm going a little bit,
maybe that's just because I probably should practice
more, but I would definitely
say kind of at that last bit with
once I know I'm in the home stretch, I just have
a few moves left, it just kind of, I would say
that maybe that's kind of when it's flowing the most, I know
I can just kind of do that jump into the
key up. I actually felt much more confident
than I did in my practice for
the, the key upping,
just because I was like, yeah, that's it, I'm done, don't have to
worry about it as much.
Uh, decently clean turn and finish,
but, yeah.
Okay. Um.
So,
looking for more information on
how you're scored. So,
as you can see, your
pattern is scored, uh, based
on the number ten. So, out of
ten is your, is your one.
Uh, as you can see, it's split
up into two parts. We have our
accuracy and our presentation
on this side. So, we'll start off with the accuracy
first. So, uh, your
accuracy is actually scored from
a four. So,
from the number four, uh,
you're actually marked during your,
uh, presentation of your pattern.
And then, with that one, any
mistakes that you make, whether,
if it's a minor mistake, you get, uh,
minus of a zero point one.
If it's a major mistake,
you get minus zero point three.
So, I'll, I'll just let you guys
know about the difference between the two.
So, with a minor mistake, it's, uh,